citizens of the reject Nation it is at
last time to not only make a new common
corner hello and thank you for coming
back and being so excited for this but
also to break down the DC slate by
excitement I love making these lists to
you guys and I know there's gonna be a
lot of stuff we're going to talk about
that slate but I thought first of all
let's do broad Strokes just what we're
the most excited about so please do let
me know in the comments which one that
you're the most excited about which
announcement you thought was the most
surprising what your order of excitement
is and now all of this could change
because we've literally got nothing
except the shape of the story via tone
announced by comic which made me very
happy and the announcement itself so
this isn't what's going to be best when
it arrives it's what level of excitement
we're at right now from these
announcements now we're going to focus
on the 10 new announcements we knew
about the Batman 2 very excited to get
the title in the release date but we're
not including that one we're just doing
the 10 new properties please do leave a
like subscribe hit that notification
Bell and let's get into it
first up number 10 my number 10 is the
Creature Commandos now this one is just
on the lower side because this is not a
property I particularly have a lot of
investment in a lot of connection to I
was only vaguely aware of it existing I
I had heard of it but I didn't really
have a lot of context it's an early 80s
comic and it's about World War II if my
memory serves and it's animated now I am
excited for the animated two live-action
Crossover with the actors I think that
has a lot of potential I think them
saying that is a very strong seed
planted but I generally connect to live
action more than animation and I
generally connect to characters whose
books I've read that's the only reason
this one's number 10 but something had
to be last number 10 Creature Commandos
coming in at number nine is Paradise
Lost now this could conceptually land
with the Paradise Island Lost comic book
that's a two issue story arc that's very
solid but it doesn't seem to be so I
think the reason this one's so low for
me is I really love the character of
Wonder Woman I think she's the third of
the Holy Trinity of DC and without
knowing what place Wonder Woman has in
this the mascara story I can't put it
higher that yet this one has probably
the most potential to go from number
nine to my top three because like I said
I do love Wonder Woman if this is a soft
origin for a Wonder Woman show if this
is launching Wonder Woman's own corner
of the universe any of those things this
could really work for me but as far as
just the mascara as a westeros-esque
world as a Game of Thrones s thing I'm
not as big into Game of Thrones as most
people I really am enjoying house the
dragon actually more than Game of
Thrones but I I don't know if that
Dynamic is going to sell me as the rest
of this slate so depending on how this
sets up Wonder Woman depending on how
this sets up the amazonians depending on
what the flavor of the story for this
Westeros de mascara is time will tell
but for now it is number nine Paradise
Lost coming in at number eight and
things are accelerating now we're into
the like where do I put this I'm so
excited number eight is Waller now
Peacemaker was one of my top three shows
of last year Peacemaker is a force of
nature of telling vision and I really
think that what Peacemaker was able to
prove is that there is no character
irredeemable to James Gunn I loved his
The Suicide Squad but I definitely found
myself going like yeah I love the
dichotomy and Duality between Idris Elba
and John Cena but that's what sells me
on Peacemaker is he's that exception
he's the outside and then the show
showed me oh my God not only is John
Cena a Powerhouse actor but the way that
James Gunn can make me care about anyone
I immediately loved all the Guardians of
the Galaxy I immediately loved the
characters because of their underdogness
but Peacemaker is not a great dude in
The Suicide Squad and then they are able
to give him texture and flavor and build
all those things out I think that's what
we're gonna get with Waller I think
Viola Davis is I mean it's Violet Davis
I think Amanda Waller is a character
we've only seen as like this very
intense badass authority figure I think
if they add some layers to her we've
already met her daughter we'd have some
you know mother-daughter moments I think
you can really grow Amanda Waller in her
own show and I think the idea of a
peacemaker spin-off is incredible very
excited about all the the pieces of the
puzzle but I don't know how involved
James Gunn is and he is a key factor for
my enjoyment of Peacemaker I think his
ability to make us love the unlikable
character is a huge factor and I don't
know how much he's involved in this show
so while I'm excited to see Waller grow
as a character while I'm excited to see
The Peacemaker World grow out this has
to be on the Lower Side just because I
am concerned about the Cameo elements of
working in a show in a universe that's
just starting with this character and
with perhaps me just wanting more of a
peacemaker season two and three and
Beyond and because my next seven are
would be in the top 10 of most years
lists so it gets uh very hard to decide
between A's and a minuses going forward
coming in at number seven is the
authority The Authority is probably my
biggest surprise of the entire
announcement other than one comic
specifically being named later on but
the authority is a wild storm comic in
my mind it is a comic that's a imprint
of DC and was kind of merged with DC but
what makes this interesting is wild
storms The Authority was a commentary on
the Justice League there are literally
two members of this that are pretty much
one-to-one parallel commentaries on our
two biggest heroes in the Justice League
Batman and Superman are midnighter and
Apollo it's literally the god of the sun
Apollo midnight or Dark Knight but I
don't think there's ever been a universe
where the commentary on the character is
in the same universe as the character I
think the closest might be Deadpool
because he's kind of a a play on
Spider-Man but he's not a commentary in
Spider-Man it's different there's a meta
awareness there that isn't as present
here because Deadpool's kind of like a
mix between Spider-Man Wolverine
um Snake Eyes like those characters
whereas this is what would these
characters be in another world it'd be
like a Superman red Sun was in the Saint
Peter versus Superman so I'm very
curious about the tone of this I'm very
curious about how they're going to make
this work in world because again it's
not an else world it's in the DCU so I'm
very excited to see an anti-justice
league in the Justice League and there's
a reason I put uh Waller and the
authority together because I do think
that Waller is going to lead to the
authority I think that's it's not
coincidence we're getting a Waller comic
book this year that deals with wildstorm
I think that the authority Waller combo
is going to go right into each other and
I think we're going to build out a very
interesting anti-justice League that
again is going to be very dissimilar
from The Suicide Squad much like we've
got Thunderbolts and the dark Avengers
and Marvel I think the anti-justice
league and The Suicide Squad are gonna
have some interesting commentaries on
what that looks like and I'm very
excited for it coming in at number six
is a property I have waited years for
lanterns we are getting a lantern show
now this would already be very high up
on any most anticipated of the year list
but the fact that James Gunn
specifically said True Detective True
Detective season one is probably one of
the best seasons of Television of all
time hardstop I was gonna quantify that
but it's literally I think one of the
best seasons of TV so if you're going
for that tone and you're setting a
terrestrial Green Lantern world with
they I think they described it as a
substation Earth then you've got a very
interesting thing afoot because he said
the mystery inland interns is tied into
the whole DCU so this could be a big bad
they're leading to at the end of chapter
one this could be uh maybe like the
anti-life equation this could be
something that ties into the greater
universe that these detectives these
space cops have to solve on Earth add to
that we finally get Jon Stewart in live
action add to that we haven't had Hal
Jordan but once really in live action
and that wasn't the greatest thing it's
kind of a cautionary tale of superheroes
I think that this show on HBO is going
to be a huge weekly Conversation Piece I
loved one division because it was a
mystery I loved True Detective because
it was an adult mystery this might give
us the opportunity for a superhero adult
mystery conversation show that we talk
about every single week that has the
[__] Green Lantern core this is so
exciting number five Booster Gold
Booster Gold is so ripe for today I want
to make a whole video about Booster Gold
I might but I really think one of the
most interesting things about this is
that we're living in an age where where
social media is everything and it's only
exponential and by the time 2025 rolls
around and this show comes out it's
going to be so much worse than it is now
and this is a character from the future
that comes to today to be cool this is
an unlikable not the greatest guy that
grows into a hero his first Arc in the
comic books is kind of an anti-hero
Superman's trying to figure out where he
came from he hides the fact that he's
from the future because he wants to seem
like he has powers he has Tech from the
future that basically gives him Powers
today but I love that commentary on
futurism on tradition on what makes a
hero on anti-heroes on basically being a
hero for likes does it make you a hero
if you're only helping people for
popularity does it make you a good
person if you're only commenting on
things negatively to get likes does it
make you good if you're yelling into the
void about not enjoying certain comic
books and certain properties to get more
likes on Tick Tock viewer I don't think
it does and so Booster Gold kind of
represents giant insecurities and
trolling but to a superhero scale there
are so many people that do this that
talk about especially comic books and
movies that say Really really ignorant
stuff to get attention I love using a
superhero to turn that on its head and
yeah I got a hundred things to say we
gotta do a Booster Gold Video if you
want to see a Booster Gold video I got a
lot to say leave a comment below very
excited about this character to get the
live action screen treatment number four
Batman the Brave and the Bold we're
getting the bat family we're getting a
version of Batman we have not seen in a
very long time the furthest we've gotten
in live action Batman with the bat
family was Robin and that was in the
very tricky to navigate Schumacher
movies and I think the drill Schumacher
movies could have been very special I
think Joel Schumacher is a very very
talented director but I think that was a
time when Studio involvement was so much
so that it's basically to sell toys now
we're living in entire age where the the
actual IP matters we're living in an age
where Batman himself matters where
people are lobbying for a dick racer
people are lobbying for a Tim Drake
where people are are wondering is Jason
Todd gonna be the Red Hood these are
characters that are known and loved now
they're not just things to sell toys and
so living in an age where the bat family
is known living in an age where we've
been wanting this so badly and living in
an age where I think the best strength
of this property is in the fact that
Damien Wayne is a bit of a monster and
thus has to change Bruce Wayne and thus
has to make him a little bit lighter is
a beautiful way to set up the dichotomy
between this Batman and Pattinson that's
how you're able to have two Batman in
one slate we're in 2025 we're looking at
having two Batman right now we've got so
many we've got Michael Keaton we've got
Ben Affleck we got you know been we just
had bail we've got Pattinson but it's
going to be two very different Batman
and not only does that show the strength
of the character but it allows them to
exist simultaneously and show why
there's so many Batman comics and we get
the bat family and we get characters
we've wanted to see on screen I again
will talk a lot about that in another
video but Batman is going to be very
different very soon and that is is very
exciting for fans of the Pattinson and
the Neil Adams and the the fun 66 take a
like coming in at number three is Swamp
Thing now this one is really hard to
even quantify I think the reason I'm so
excited about this one is if they hit
the mark this is doing Watchmen right
this is making Sandman for Netflix
correctly this is the potential to make
something that's so avant-garde and
existential but also horrific but also
full of heart the comic book they showed
is a Swamp Thing winter special which is
a pretty recent Comics Tom King and it
is a love letter to the writer who
invented it while also being a
commentary on mortality and I'm
protecting and on safety and on what it
means to be human while dealing with a
non-human character and there's so much
magic and mysticism inherent to Swamp
Thing there's so much interesting lore
there's so much mythology Swamp Thing
can lead to just slick dark or not Swamp
Thing can lead to entire mystical worlds
this is is as big of an opening as Dr
Strange to an exponential scale this is
as big of an opening to a new world as
when James Gunn did Guardians it changes
the potential for everything and if they
can set this up as a horror story that
also has all of these very deep heady
thoughts that we're in for poetry the
movie this is a beautiful poem of a
character and I honestly think this
could be the most interesting and
experimental comic book movie we've ever
seen if it's handled right and I'm
hearing it might be James Mangold uh he
posted a picture of a very stunning
Bernie wrightson uh piece of Swamp Thing
art and that to me it's like 1201 by the
way like two days ago like the night at
the Slate uh he posted a Bernie writes
in piece and I'm like I don't know why
James I mean maybe James Manuel is just
a fan but I wanted James mangled can you
imagine slither's producer in James Gunn
and the director of Logan and James
mangle doing a Swamp Thing very high
potential for this beauty very excited
coming in at number two and this is 100
percent event going to be another video
breakout as well because this is a
conversation I've been wanting to have
for quite some time and I've been having
it uh you know with my friends and I've
been having it uh briefly on Twitter but
I want to dive into it and that is why
we need a new Superman and this is going
to be Superman Legacy and the art used
is Frank Whiteley beautiful stunning
cover art from All-Star Superman written
by Grant Morrison one of the most
hopeful powerful colorful uplifting
Superman stories in years I have been
very on the record for saying how much I
love Henry Cavill I have been very on
the record for saying how much of a
bummer it is that the cost of this
reboot seems to be Henry Cavill but
honestly I do think Superman Legacy will
show us the importance of the character
to the world it's so hard to even say
this without sounding cheesy but that's
kind of the fun of Superman is he can be
cheesy but he's so good that works and
that is this this is the statement
Superman can make the world better and I
want a King Superman movie that makes
the world better I want people to look
at this this figure this this pop
culture icon and want to Aspire to be
better and we have not had that in a
very long time and when Superman was
invented the world was very dark and he
was a commentary on Hope and getting out
of the darkness and right now the world
is very dark I would like a character to
pull us out of the darkness so yeah I'm
I'm literally calling on Superman to
save us and bring back truth justice in
the American way and I honestly think if
handled right it's a very important
movie on not just a movie scale on a
worldwide scale we need Superman frankly
and I'm very excited for this take and
my number one most anticipated of that
slate Supergirl I honestly I like
Supergirl I really do I think she's a
fantastic character but I also find her
to be a character that is very very hard
to write a lot like her cousin Superman
but one of the arcs that I love most one
of my favorite comic book arcs of any
character not just Supergirl but in
comic books is Supergirl woman of
tomorrow and they are directly not
inspired by not in regards to not
lovingly they are adapting Supergirl
woman of tomorrow and it looks like I'm
pretty sure it's confirmed Tom King is
writing this this is Tom King adapting
his comic book to the screen this is one
of the best writers in comic books
making a screenplay out of this this is
Tom King who was supposed to be working
with New Gods way back in the day
finally making a movie and this is a guy
who was a an agent for the states he
worked for the CIA who then wrote one of
the best Batman of all time who then
went on to make my favorite DC Comic of
all time Mr Miracle who then went on to
redefine in my mind Supergirl and
Superman and if he's directly adapting
his own story that redefines Supergirl
for me in a way that is a commentary on
what it's like to be isolated alone what
it's like to feel alien what it's like
to have these Powers what it's like to
be a hero what it's like to do the Dirty
Work what it's like to help someone do
something you don't want them to do
because you'd rather shoulder that bird
burden this could be all of that in Star
Wars this is a giant sci-fi space epic
this the scope of this is magnificent
and wonderful and powerful and the
morals and themes and human element make
it so so important while being so
stunning and beautiful the art in this
book is transcendent the story in this
book makes you a better person and the
way you connect to Supergirl a character
again that I like but don't know to love
is so impactful this could make a
character that a lot of people don't
give the time of day into an a-lister
this could make a character that a lot
of people see as like oh girl Superman
no no Supergirl is her own thing and
that's the point of Supergirl living in
her cousin's Shadow how do you live in
your cousin's Superman Shadow and be a
hero this is beautiful and the fact that
she's on her own at the beginning of her
life she like was born on an asteroid
the isolation the underdogness honestly
I I I'm gonna talk I'm gonna make 100
videos we're gonna make so many videos
about this late but that is my number
one pick I am very very excited for
Supergirl I love woman of tomorrow I
highly recommend you read it it is an
eight issue Mini series I'm gonna give
you some comic book Recs actually right
now Supergirl one through eight woman of
tomorrow it is uh last year I think 2020
it started 2021 and ended maybe 21-22
check it out eight issues Tom King I
would also recommend highly if you're
interested at all in uh any of these
characters I would say that you could
dive into some weird stuff with Swamp
Thing I think the Alan Moore stuff is
very very important go back to the Lynn
ween stuff if you like the Alan Moore
stuff there's something called American
Gothic that's a pretty solid collection
that I think would suit you I think if
you want to check out anything with the
authority it's a linear you can just get
one through twelve like and then if you
like that you can go on to the next but
it is a linear path you don't have to
read a bunch of comics it is it is one
Journey with the authority because
they're a commentary they're not in the
world yet they do get in the world
Superman comes in you'll see but I'm
very excited about all that also that's
a good point Superman coming into the
authority was very interesting because
of that commentariness them just jumping
into the DCU fascinated but those are my
top 10 most anticipated by hype by
excitement what are you you most excited
for let me know in the comments below
which of these was your most surprising
what is your order I like lists I'll
read your list and uh overall what are
you thinking 2025 is going to look like
by the time we get there for superhero
Cinema and what do you want to see the
difference of the TV shows be either way
talk about this slate a lot if you want
to see more of this let me know what
else you want me to talk about in the
comments below you guys are my co-host I
tell you what you want to hear about
it's up to you let me know in the
comments you want more comic wrecks let
me know you want more stories let me
know thank you to you reject Nation
we'll see you soon
[Music]